[Musique]
des toiles de jouy ou des indiennes une
quarantaine de toiles à personnages sont
exposés ici au musée de la toile de jouy
à jouy en josas étoffes et littérature
décrit les liens entre les ouvrages et
ses tissus imprimés très populaire au
18ème 19ème siècle il était utilisé pour
l'ameublement principalement pour la
chambre qui nous permettent donc de
rêver de se souvenir pas de télévision
n'a pas de radio
comment est-ce qu'on se souvient de ce
qu'on a lu de ce qu'on a vu au théâtre
parce qu'on a entendu à l'opéra on va
avoir des toiles littéraire
e
cette exposition permet de comprendre
une société fasciné par l'ailleurs
l'amour ou encore l' aventure ce sont
d'ailleurs ces six désir qui divise
l'exposition des grands navigateurs
comme cook ou encore deux bogeys en
ville vous apporter cet esprit de
découverte dans les toiles on va
retrouver énormément de motifs comme l'a
par exemple un cocotier ou d'autres
civilisations comme ici les aztèques des
statuts des cactus ses toiles permettent
aussi de comprendre quelles étaient les
grands ouvrages qui plaisait à une
époque et qui pour nous aujourd'hui non
plus d'impact comme nina ou la folle par
amour mais d'autres oeuvres sont encore
très populaires exemple les fables de la
fontaine un oiseau sur un arbre et un
animal à quatre pattes en dessous le
corbeau et le renard la manufacture au
barcamp semble être à l'origine de ce
courant en france ses toiles sont
imprimés sur une plaque de cuivre très
rarement elles peuvent être imprimés
également la planche de bois
[Musique]